To get started, let's replace
the hashtag in our delete link
with the path for
/restaurants/idnumber/delete.
Here, inside my doGet block, I make a
confirmation page that informs the user
that they are about to delete
a restaurant from the database.
Within it, I create a POST form that
only contains the button element to
confirm the delete.
Then I use wfile to write my
output back out to the client.
Similarly to my edit post,
I grab the ID part of my URL and
create a query to find
that restaurant object.
I then call session.delete on the object
and commit the delete to the database.
I redirect once again to
the main restaurants page.
Let's save our code and
fire up the server one more time.
And we see that we can now create,
read, update, and
delete via our web page,
all objectives complete.
And of course, the source code for
objective five can also be
found in the instructor notes.